hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and welcome to episode 123 of game
programming so minutes earlier I
recorded episode 122 as you can
literally quite see minutes have passed
and as soon as I finished recording that
and I set up some editing and whatnot I
realized that hang on the reason we were
probably getting a class cast exception
with everything else was because the
format wasn't actually an integer okay
so this format you can see we set up
with int which is why obviously costumes
to a data buffer in probably makes sense
however the image that we loaded must
not have been that format so just to
ease my curiosity I'm going to go ahead
and print the type of the image and see
that it's type six whatever the hell
that means so let's go into above an
image and see what the types are so what
are these are defined so six is actually
so it's a full byte Abgar okay so that
is why it didn't work out so it looks
like it's butter isn't lives in a single
bottle right okay so it's just a byte
array a PG art which means that it's
going to be a byte array that's four
times as large as the amount of pixels
and it's just going to be the first bar
is gonna be a so index zero will be a
then index one will be our and then of
BGR it looks like so B then G then our
okay that's all interleave just means
that it's kind of hint early that it's
hard to just say actually I'm pretty
sure yeah so excuse me so it just means
that um if we want to access a
particular int it'll be a particular
channel of color first of all we don't
have to split them off using an D
essentially or masking we just we could
just grab it using the I guess we can
just grab it using just the you know
byte array indices and that's it so one
thing I want to focus on today the next
big thing we'll be doing is actually
creating a mini-map and I want to save
that for next time because there's a few
things I want to do here and I don't
want to I don't want to show everything
into one episode like I did last time so
um we've got some buttons there are a
few things that are wrong first of all
you can see that we shoot
even if we click on these buttons that's
a bit annoying I want to fix that but
then the other thing I want to fix is
actually this right I don't want to have
this here but I do want a nice easy way
to brighten something so I'm going to
introduce something in util called image
utils okay and these things are going to
be stuff like I want to increase the
brightness of an image of mine again and
we'll return a new image
so public this will be a static class so
we'll go ahead and we'll actually create
a private constructor just so no one is
tempted to make instances of this class
ever and then we'll go ahead and excuse
me and we'll say something like public
static buffered image whoo
what's a good day for this change
brightness why not
so we'll take you in a buffered image
original and then so this will actually
create for it's a new image this will
actually write in your image and then
below us they say into the amounts okay
and then this will basically do kind of
what we did we did here except we'll
clean up the code a lot so if I come
over here and I grab pretty much all
this let's just cut that and we'll paste
it here for now so this is going to be
the result
we should have another version with this
doesn't actually that actually modifies
the existing one instead of having to
create a another one but I guess that's
okay we will actually take in an array
of pixels the reason is that there are
so many different types and I don't want
to have to deal with the type of the
image and then figure out how to put
that into it it's just a mess so we
won't do that here we will have a result
though and I guess if we do that that we
need width and height okay we'll make
this work with just default images I
think because it's getting it's already
getting a bit messy so we'll have the
original get with and get hard over here
and then we'll make the new one in the
format a RGB okay but they'll as you can
see it's it's in so over here will will
cast now the the old one again it was a
data buffer and but that's not what we
want anymore
what we want instead is something in the
image package so I was hoping to see
what was in there because I don't know
everything
maybe this will list the available ones
no looks like google it is so Java dot
dot image right was that is this where
this is yes it is hmm so let's take a
look at this data buffer bias is
probably what it's going to be I mean I
imagine I was wondering if there was a
special one for the interleaved kind of
by variant but I guess not so we'll go
ahead and cost that to that and then we
will obviously changes to be a broad
array and it's still still sad
okay let's import that and it should be
good now yeah so we don't need to do any
of this anymore so we've got the
so we've got the other pixels these are
the original pixels right so what we'll
do is we'll brighten it by a set amount
now what we don't have mm that we should
have is a math utils class I'm sure we
had something like this but looks like
we don't again this will be beginning a
lot of stuff done this will be again a
static kind of deal and the reason I'm
doing this is I literally just want a
clamp thing and that's this okay so
basically we have a value and we want to
clamp it between a minimum and maximum
so we're basically saying that if if the
value is less than minimum then just
return a minimum if the value is greater
than maximum return maximum okay so it
makes sure that the value that we feed
into this will never be between it would
sorry will always be between minimum and
maximum and never outside that so
basically all we have to do is we have
to say that if value is less than
minimum then we return minimum otherwise
if value is greater than maximum return
maximum otherwise we return value all
right I could have probably written this
as some kind of in Lion weird thing I'm
not gonna waste too much time on that
and in fact since we are here I will
actually make a public static int min so
this will just return whichever one is
smaller so value is less than min sorry
whichever one is yeah so we're 10 min
otherwise I will return value okay so
all this means is that if value is less
than minimum then we'll return minimum
okay because we don't want it to go
beneath a minimum I like return value
and we'll do the same thing for max
there's just a nice little methods to
have as we start working with plant
values and one-off value greater than
then we'll return in max otherwise value
okay we've got some nice map details the
reason I did that is because of
something I'm about to show you now
original mmm don't get height I get with
and then pixels and then original don't
get with okay so we've got these we've
separated the channels now what I'm
going to do is I'm actually going to say
that our is going to equal math utils in
fact I'm going to I don't want to write
Matthew tails every time so I'm going to
import a statically so if you type an
import static and then what was it
calm daughter Janet of rain dot util dot
math utils dot asterisks you know
basically import every static method as
if it was kind of in this class or in
this namespace so what that means is
that I can just basically call clamp
instead of having to do math utils clamp
so it's quite nice but basically all I'm
going to do is it's gonna be our floss
and math so you can feed it a negative
amount but I'm gonna clamp that between
0 and 255 okay simple as that
and I'm basically going to repeat that
for the other ones as well so you can
see how easy it is it makes sure it
basically just lets us not have a bunch
of if statements in here which would
make everything really messy so that's
nice now the result pixels okay results
pixels will be kind of the same deal
except it looks like we're going to be
using integers so it'll be a data buffer
int okay and this will be results dot
get Rasta guitar Ababa and I've changed
that to be int okay all good and then
we'll set the result pixels to this and
you can see that we can kind of keep
exactly the same deal that we had before
and then we'll return our result okay so
that should work again I
actually I haven't I haven't written
this code and tried it out so I don't
know if this will work that that's just
what game programming is is is about
unfortunately maybe fortunately because
you get I guess you guys get to see me
debug it but um I just don't at the time
obviously to to not do that okay so
image hover is now going to be image
utils starts change rightness you know
I'll do I'll rename this to like create
brighter or something or create I don't
even know I was going to take away but
brighter but you can make it darker so
anyway so original is image and amounts
will say a hundred which is what we had
before so it should look the same
hopefully and not crash so we'll see
what happens
well that did not work of course it
didn't work properly what was I thinking
so this is different okay we can't
actually do this now what we have to do
is this assembly that we have here I'm
not sure why I just ignore that it can't
forgot this is Emily here isn't actually
this okay
so int will have to we can do this a
bunch of different ways but we'll have
some offset here and basically our is
just going to be really annoying
actually because it's to bite and by
it's a just terrible in Java
maybe we can cast it to an int and it
will work there probably was no I hate
this fights and Java are worse are the
other worst because they're signed
they're not unsigned oh okay let's just
see what happens so basically this will
be pixels so we don't need this anymore
so pixels will have to get all of them
as well
pixels basically offset plus plus is
what they'll be so this will be a DF
channel so ABG are seems to be the the
pro strategy
and it's literally just this okay oh how
did that happen almost a fake control
because it's just gonna be that right
and then we can clamp them hopefully
this actually converts them into
introduce a really heavy well we can
clamp them between the values that we
need and then we can hop in a back in
okay and maybe that what hopefully
please work Oh made a doc oh man work
almost worked
I mean you know it didn't but it almost
worked so now I'm going to open my
browser and type in Java byte to int
this is what I'm walking out I'm not
gonna hide this from you guys oh really
you can just do int value Wow who knew
me would be so easy I hope this is a
solution I'm kind of just looking at the
best thing I see so we'll do this new
bite you can see why Java might be slow
because you need to create an object to
convert it to an integer are two
unsigned int that works for me it's not
a static there the Scotties starting mmm
by start to unsigned int oh this is
gonna be beautiful way what else do they
have that too I'm signed yeah long okay
hopefully this works the way I want it
to getting that returns an int yep maybe
maybe this isn't so bad after all
who knows
maybe it's not so bad Wow
okay please work
yay okay it's not so bad I swear
maybe they added this no they didn't
it's apparently that's that's from 2012
at least so anyway yay look that it
works so now what we can do is we can go
into a player and we can actually
increase or decrease the brightness
let's try put it to like negative like
50 or something right you can see that
darkens it now yeah
pretty cool so you can change any image
now okay it's pretty cool it's pretty
powerful
you can literally change any image so
yeah so it's pretty it's pretty damn
awesome
what was I going to say yes that will
create a new one so change brightness
will return I'll just make a little
javadoc comment for the first time I
think in this series that are and we
were just supposed to go it kinda looks
weird oh just nautical I don't help
there
yeah returns a new image just so people
people know and by people I mean me okay
cool
anyway that is pretty much it I'm gonna
maybe wrap up the video there all I was
going to but I remembered that I still
need to do the other thing and then one
other thing I should mention is Gerren
that one other thing I should mention is
if you wanted to do one on like pressed
or something so image pressed again
because this is so easy now you can just
do something like image pressed equally
just see how much less code that is I
mean it's you know it's madness we can
just like that and then we can be like
will override pressed I'm will set that
equal to button dot set image having
that I was holding ctrl down when I
clicked again flips buttons will set
image image pressed and I guess we'll
also need released so released we'll set
it back to image I guess alright now
we've got the whole the whole whole
thing if we click you can see it goes
brighter if we let go a little close it
but you can see if we click it goes
brighter and and when we hold we go star
currently so there we go we've got a
pretty cool thing going on and it's
really simple to do as you can see so
awesome
I wonder we probably don't even need
these because they are created on the
heap so hopefully the references will
possess I have no idea because I'm not
really an expert on how Java handles
memory but um it is gonna be a bit weird
let's see if we can do this yeah we can
okay I don't know where it's tracking
those references but it is so it's
bestest probably captured them so
everything's fine so we can't get rid of
these now we can do it the ultra risky
way this just feels weird to me but it's
probably fine because again they'll be
they'll be sitting there somewhere and
the garbage collector probably won't
touch them hopefully I mean it might
sometime in the future who knows it's
Java but you can see that everything
works perfectly now if we click the
mouse here we don't want to shoot okay
but yes but yes you can see that the way
that our mouse works and the way that
anything really works is that we
basically you can see that when we click
and we check to see if if a button is
clicked it doesn't matter anywhere now
we know where we click we can query the
get button and it will return that
now the best way I can think of fixing
that problem and by best way I really
mean best way ok because um there are
many ways you can fix that one way you
could be like yeah instantly you could
just be like in the player class if the
button
position is you know if the button
position X is greater than that then the
beginning of that panel then just uh you
know that doesn't count as put buzz
pressing a button you can do something
as simple as that and that will work
well but the proper way to do it would
be to have an actual kind of event
dispatcher system right an event
handling system so what that means is
that you basically raise an event and
everyone's everyone this is subscribed
to that event in a certain layer stack
order will receive a an event callback
so the they'll be like a non-event
method or just an event method or
whatever and then that will get called
whenever there's an event and then what
happens there is you can actually return
basically true or false true means that
you have handled the event false means
that you haven't handled the event so if
you're returning true it means that any
other layers in your stack do not
receive that event so in other words in
our stack this power would be higher in
the stack than the rest of the game
because you can see just literally on
top of it so we process the events for
that first even though we render it in
reverse order and then what happens is
we when we click here we say that
obviously if we have clicked and we've
notified that the click has been inside
the panel then we basically return true
from that event handling method which
means that other other layers behind it
won't actually receive the event because
otherwise if we return false the event
dispatcher will send it to the next
layer in the stack and it will keep
going so that's basically a quick
overview of how an event dispatcher
would work and this is more or less how
you would handle it in the real world so
this was a real game that's how we would
do it excuse me so if you guys want to
see that it's a bit complicated it's not
really complicated it's actually really
simple but it's going to take like maybe
two episodes or three episodes to do and
since this series is all about involving
you guys I am asking you if you want to
see that if you would rather see the
minimap and we just go on with this and
then just basically put it putting the
half that says that if the mouse pointer
is if the X is greater than the panel
then ignore it then
yeah we could do something like that
instead like and again that will
literally be as simple as just saying
where we do the update shooting I think
right if okay so first of all IRM you
know what the X is so it's like 660 so
if that is greater than 660 return okay
and then suddenly look he doesn't shoot
any more when we when we're over here
I'm clicking can see how I just closed
the game or I or I clicked on the hollow
button several times and you can see
it's not shooting and then he does when
you hear so you can see that you could
do something as simple as that and
that'll work but if you guys want to see
a bit of a professional ish I guess
implementation of a layer stack not
looks really professional or anything
but um I just mean that the proper way
to handle this then let me know in the
comments below and I will pay attention
to that so that's going to pretty much
wrap up this video as always you can
support me on patreon if you'd like and
for pledging $5 monthly if you pledge $5
or more per month then you get access to
all the source code from game
programming and it's all versioned so
the cool thing about that is you can
actually go to github and you can see
exactly the lines of code that I've
changed with each episode which is
awesome so you don't have to worry too
much about that yeah thanks for watching
guys I hope you enjoyed if you did
please hit the like button and I'll see
you guys next time goodbye
you